yo je me souviens d'un tweet en 2016 qui
a attiré mon attention c'est un tweet du
joueur du grenier un des youtube eux les
plus connus et respectés
et voici le tout le superman effect en
vidéo pas de lunettes personne ne me
reconnaît et voici la vidéo
pendant une convention le joueur du
grenier et devrait pas pouvoir se
déplacer sans que des fans l'arrêtent
et pourtant ils y arrivent juste en
avant ses lunettes c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'effet superman ou le superman
effect superman abbas comme vous savez
la différence entre superman et clark
kent bah c'est que clark kent il a des
lunettes quoi c'est très léger la
différence d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens
se moquent du fait que c'est pas
possible ou quoi genre quand toi clark
kent tu reconnais que c'est superman
très bizarre et bien pour nous la
question et comme une vidéo du joueur du
grenier n'est pas suffisante il nous
faut des études et ça tombe bien parce
qu'un a notamment celles ci de
l'université de york
les chercheurs ont montré à 59
participants des photos en leur
demandant s'il s'agissait de la même
personne
il y avait trois catégories de photos
les gens qui portent des lunettes
les gens qui ne portent pas de lunettes
et le mix c'est à dire une photo de
personnes qui ne portent pas de lunettes
avec une photo d'une personne qui porte
des lunettes
l'idée était de tester les compétences
de comparaison visuelle et le tout sans
contrainte de temps pour les cas on
avait le même type de photos c'est à
dire deux personnes avec des lunettes ou
bien deux personnes sans lunettes et
bien 4 1 % des gens arriver à savoir si
c'était la même personne ou non sur les
deux photos
par contre et c'est là où ça devient
intéressant quand il fallait comparer
quelqu'un qui avait des lunettes par
rapport à quelqu'un qui n'avait pas de
lunettes et bien ce taux baisse de 6%
de mon côté j'utilise le même effet pour
dissocier mais deux projets sur youtube
cyrus north et l'antisèche et ça marche
bon après moi je vais encore plus loin
puisque ça m'arrive de raser ma barbe
mais dans tous les cas on me dit
régulièrement et excuse moi tu es cyrus
north d'accord ok non parce que j'ai cru
que c'était le mec qui faisait
l'antisèche j'avais un doute
ok j'adore ce que tu veux et je vois
aussi régulièrement passer ce genre de
tweets
c'est que maintenant que j'ai capté que
le gars qui faisait les vidéos
antisèches bas c'était cyrus north pété
de rire
donc cette étude elle montre pas mal de
choses m'ont déjà que les gens de
metropolis ils sont pas si stupide ainsi
que nos lunettes
by nous définissent ça c'est moi je dois
avoir environ cinq ans et je porte déjà
des lunettes
honnêtement je me souviens pas ne pas
avoir de lunettes c'est parce que c'est
en fait ça a dû arriver forcément du
tout début de ma vie mais j'en ai
absolument aucun souvenir
j'ai l'impression d'être née avec mes
lunettes je les porte depuis environ 25
ans est quasiment tous les jours j'ai un
peu essayé les lentilles évitait mais
c'est pas trop mon truc
puis je me rends compte qu'en fait voilà
les lunettes ça fait partie de moi
j'aime bien ça et vous rendez compte
depuis 25 ans quasiment tous les jours
j'ai vraiment accepter qu'ils aient une
aide ça fait partie de mon identité
littéralement j'observe le monde à
travers mes lunettes
c'est un peu difficile de les voir comme
un objet indépendant j'ai vraiment sensé
une extension de moi et ben je me vois
pas vivre sans elle quoi un peu comme un
cyborg voir un truc technologique qui
s'accroche à vous un peu comme la
relation qu'on a avec nos téléphones
qu'on a tout le temps avec nous ce qui
joue en revanche c'est que les lunettes
c'est pas un petit bijou technologique
enfin c'est ce que je croyais ya
quelques semaines j'ai été contacté par
essilor france pour parler des verres de
lunettes et s'est même pas pour parler
des verts et si laurent particulier mais
c'est plus pour vous parler de voile à
déconstruire des idées reçues sur toute
la complexité autour de verres de
lunettes par exemple en plus j'en ai
profité parce que c'est un super
interlocuteur pour poser plein de
questions en rapport avec la technologie
et les verts puisqu'ils sont à la pointe
de la technologie de verre vous
connaissez sûrement le verre progressif
c'est des verts qui corrige la presbytie
c'est un truc qu'on va à peu près tout
savoir c'est que en gros quand et
presbytes ou presbyte on peut pas faire
la mise au point sur les trucs qui sont
proches
et quand on vieillit sa touche à peu
près tout le monde est donc le ils ont
créé un verre donc on appelle progressif
qui s'appelle le vin et luxe est en fait
suivant où vous regardez dans le vert
vous allez voir net ce qui est loin
intermédiaires ou près et ça ça date de
1959 et donc en discutant avec eux en
fait je me suis rendu compte que c'est
une vraie prouesse technique en fait de
faire des verres de lunettes et j'avais
jamais vraiment porté attention
j'avais jamais vu ça sous cet oeil ouais
c'est en train de faire le montage est
en fait ça veut rien dire voir les
choses sous cet oeil soit c'est voir du
bébé ou voir d'un autre oeil
soit c'est voir les choses sous cet
angle voilà donc la blague ne marche pas
du tout et donc j'avais plein de
questions et vraiment je partais de loin
par exemple alors ça paraît peut-être
évident pour beaucoup d'entre vous est
ce que vous saviez que genre les verres
de lunettes
ces genres c'est pas du verre en fait ce
genre du plastique or c'est un plastique
hyper complexe
voilà c'est l'hyper technique et tout
mais c'est pas du verre et c'est marrant
parce que ça paraît évident et pourtant
j'en ai parlé à plein des gens qui ont
des lunettes et à chaque fois les gens
étaient là je n aie pas et c est en fait
c'est parce que si c'était du verre ça
aurait été trop lourd
ça a été aussi trop cassant et donc
dangereux
évident quand on y pense mais en fait on
n'y pense pas quoi c'est ça le truc
donc je me suis dit que c'était
l'occasion de se poser un peu des
questions sur usenet et savoir un peu ce
qu'on porte sur les yeux quoi et pour y
répondre il fallait un expert fallait
quelqu'un qui sait je m'appelle denis
mazu et je suis directeur contre saumur
expérience en recherche et développement
chez essilor et je sais tu toi c'est
mieux constitua où c'est mieux quand je
vous vois conservation tutoie on a un
challenge un peu paradoxal c'est que
l'objet qu'on doit améliorer l'objet sur
lequel on travaille c'est un objet qui a
vocation à être invisible donc nous
notre métier c'est de rajouter la
technologie de l'intelligence du design
du savoir faire à quelque chose qui est
condamné à ne pas être vus parce que
avoir la meilleure paire de lunettes du
monde c'est ne pas l'avoir c'est voir
parfaitement le monde au travers mais
qui ait aucun obstacle le deuxième
challenge qu'on a c'est que cette
invisibilité
elle est différente pour chacun si je
prends ma paire de lunettes et que je
les change avec la tienne tu vas rien
voir je vais rien voir on s'en rend pas
compte mais on peut considérer qu'il ya
aucune chance qu'on rencontre dans notre
vie quelqu'un qui a exactement la même
prescription soit donc on fait un objet
qui est totalement sur mesure c'est un
objet donc qui est invisible transparent
qui n'appartient qu'à soi c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement intime tout ça
ça représente plein de challenge
technologique au niveau de la recherche
au niveau de la fabrication mais qu'on
est condamné à masquer d'une certaine
manière
à quoi ça ressemblerait les verres de
lunettes de demain
jean vide de janvier un peu de retourner
la question et je veux dire autrement
souvent j'ai la réaction de gens qui se
disent bas mais en fait comment ça se
fait qu'il ya encore de la recherche sur
les verres de lunettes
parce que finalement on voit des vieux
films des vieilles photos il ya des gens
qui portent des lunettes et puis ça
ressemble beaucoup à ce qu'on porte
aujourd'hui d'une certaine manière les
gens qui me posent cette question là ces
gens qui sont heureux parce que ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui la paire de lunettes
qui portent éventuellement leur pose pas
de problème pour moi le verre de lunette
de demain c'est l'ensemble des verres de
lunettes qui ont répondu qu'ils vont
répondre à tous les problèmes que les
gens se posent
il ya un truc qui concerne pas
directement les lunettes de tous les
jours mais c'est les lunettes de gamer
je pense que vous avez déjà vu ce genre
il ya des gamer ils ont des lunettes sur
des filtres jaune la place des yeux et
je me suis toujours demandé si c'était
bien pas bien pourquoi alors oui c'est
par rapport à la lumière bleue à quel
point c'est bien pas bien à quel point
c'est nocif
je pose la question les écrans souvent
maîtres de la lumière bleue dans la
lumière bleue il ya une partie qui est
bleu violette qu'on a montré comme étant
nocives notamment pour la rétine
et puis il ya une partie qui est un peu
plus proche du verre qui est un peu plus
bleu turquoise qui elle est quelque
chose qui est utile au corps humain
parce que c'est la fréquence qui va
apporter les bons stimuli à notre
horloge biologique
la lumière bleue ou du moins une partie
de la lumière bleue est une lumière
qu'on a montrées pouvant être
dangereuses pour l'oeil et souvent les
verts qui en protège et qui en protège
le mieux peuvent avoir une teinte
légèrement jaune mais effectivement
puisque quand on enlève le bleu d'une
lumière il reste du jaune pour faire
simple
alors petite précision il ya des verts
qui protègent de la lumière bleue mais
qui sont pas du tout jaune par exemple
cela et pour ceux que ça intéresse j'ai
aussi visité un laboratoire c'est allah
ou fabriquent les verts et ça se fait il
y en a plein exemple à en france et là
on était en banlieue de paris
est ce que je trouve fou c'est que c'est
une production quasi industrielle terre
que vraiment on va ça s'enchaîne avec
des machines etc
et pourtant chaque verre est unique
c'est du sur mesure
donc c'est vraiment hyper complexe de
d'avoir autant de production et en même
temps de faire un produit qui est sûr
mais perso j'ai vu ça nulle pareille or
aucune autre industrie alors au niveau
des traitements et les trucs qui se font
avec une précision
moléculaire est vraiment décadenasser
vraiment moléculaire je m'attendais pas
à ça j'ai fait cette vidéo je me suis
rendu compte que je connaissais très
très mal en fait ce que j'avais sur le
net alors que ça va pas du tout avec ma
personnalité ça que généralement je sais
pas quand je vais acheter un mort dit où
je vais acheter une caméra ou ou même
quand je m'étais renseigné pour mon
expérience vraiment j study le truc à
fond je compare plein de trucs je
regarde plein de tests etc et les
lunettes qui sont aussi un produit
technique
il ya par exemple de lentilles reflète
d'ailleurs regardez ce que vous voyez
des reflets lentilles salissures de
l'hydro phobies et avant cette vidéo
jamais je m'y intéresse ce qui est hyper
chou et c'est vraiment ça qui m'a marqué
en faisant en écrivant cette vidéo c'est
pour ça je trouve ça vraiment pertinent
de vous partager ça parce que souvent on
va juste chez l'opticien ou dit vas-y et
même le blog sienne propose des trucs
qu'on paye ouais ok ok on sait même pas
ce que c'est alors que ça se trouve il
ya et verts qui sont parfaits pour ce
qu'on a l'habitude de faire juste un
exemple hyper précis j'ai appris que
voilà il est des verts qui sont anti
buée de ouf
mais deux coups qui sont hyper compliqué
ça demande un traître enfin sa demande
de s'en occuper tous les deux jours pour
mettre un produit je pas quoi donc c'est
pas pour moi mais en fait pour les
cuistots c'est pour les cuisiniers et ou
parce qu'ils ont de la buée tout le
temps et tout je suis sûr il ya plein de
cuisinier qui sont pas au courant c'est
sûr donc encore une fois merci à essilor
de m'avoir permis de faire cette vidéo
et de m'avoir appris tout ça elle m'a
voire même changé ma conception pas des
lunettes quoi et on se voit très vite
pour une prochaine vidéo
ciao